hey this is press to
Walker we have a couple of fun problems
to calculate the
areas problem one start with the right
triangle on one leg construct a
semicircle with the radius equal to
three on the other leg construct a
semicircle with the radius equal to four
the two semicircles intersect along the
hypotenuse of the right
triangle what is the value of the
following shaded areas these are the
areas of the semicircle outside the
right triangle and their overlap inside
the right
triangle this is from the 2023 ukmt IMC
question 21 and I thank Raphael for the
suggestion problem
two there's an interesting history to
the 50 P coin until about the 1500s
Europe mostly used Roman numerals and
were slow to adopt the decimal numeral
system that origin ated in India prior
to
1971 there were 12 pennies to a shilling
and 20 shillings to a
pound after decimalization the pound was
divided into 100 p and that meant new
coins such as the one pence 5 Pence 10 p
and 50 P
coin but the 50 P design proved
difficult it needed to be identifiable
by touch sight size size weight and it
must roll smoothly because many things
such as parking meters and vending
machines required coins that
rolled so how did they figure it out
eventually they consulted with
mathematical textbooks and thought of
Rulo polygons which are shapes of
constant width here are a few Rulo
polygons the most famous is the Rulo
triangle what's interesting about all of
these shapes is that they're form formed
by taking a polygon and then having
circular arcs centered at each vertex of
the
polygon this gives the interesting
property that as you roll any of these
shapes it will be a constant width
you're not going to change the height as
this coin is
rolling so now to the mathematical
problem the 50 P coin is mathematically
made up of seven equal arcs where each
each Arc is formed by a circle that's
centered on the vertex opposite the
midpoint of the
arc if each of these circles have a
radius equal to one show that the area
of the coin is equal to piun /
2us 7 / 2 multiplied by the tangent of
piun /
14 I thank McKenzie for the suggestion
this problem is adapted from the 1987
step specimen paper one and the step
specimen paper is a test that's used in
University admissions in such places as
Cambridge and the University of
Warwick pause the video if you'd like to
give these problems a try and when
you're ready keep watching to learn how
to solve these
[Music]
problems let's solve problem
one so how do we get started first we'll
calculate the side length of the right
triangle this length is three and this
length will be four so the side lengths
are six and eight now let's label each
region let's say this is a this is B
this is C this is D and this is e we
want to calculate a + C plus
e let's write down equations for areas
that we can calculate much easier we
know that a plus b plus C will be the
area of the semicircle with the radius
equal to 3 C + D + e will be the area of
the semicircle with the radius equal to
4 finally B+ C plus d will be the area
of the right triangle with legs of 6 and
8 so let's manipulate these
equations let's imagine adding the first
two equations so we get a + b + c plus c
plus d plus e then we'll subtract the
third equation so we're subtracting B
plus c plus d now notice the B's will
cancel one of the C terms will cancel
and this D term will cancel we are left
with a plus c plus e which is exactly
what we want to calculate so now we just
need to do this
calculation we take the sum of the areas
of the semicircles and subtract the area
of the right triangle so the first
semicircle has an area of Pi * 3^ 2 / 2
the second is < * 4^ 2 / 2 and the right
triangle has an area of 6 * 8/ 2 so this
simplifies to be 9 piun / 2 + 16 piun /
2 - 24 which equal 25 piun / 2 - 24
which is approximately equal to
15270 and that's the answer to the first
problem now let's solve problem two
so how can we solve the problem let's
first rotate the coin our strategy is we
are going to figure out the area of this
pizza slice this goes to the center of
the coin now notice this pizza slice is
not a circular sector although it looks
like one the circular sector for the arc
is actually centered at the opposite
vertex which is shown by the blue
circular
sector but but what we're going to do is
we're going to figure out the area of
one of these green slices and then we
can multiply it by seven to figure out
the area of the entire
coin so let's figure that out let's zoom
in now let's suppose the central angle
of this pizza slice is equal to a now if
we go all the way around from the center
that will of course be
360° or 2 pi radians so a will be 1/ 7
of 2 pi radians so a is equal to 2 piun
/
7 let's now form this straight line
segment constructing two isosceles
triangles let's label each of these
angles as
B now we know that if we go all the way
around we're going to be 2 pi radians so
we have 2 b + a is equal to 2 pi so we
can solve this equation for B to get
that b B is equal to 6 piun / 7 now we
formed two congruent Isles
triangles so the remaining angles will
be equal to each other and let's say
they're equal to C so we have C and
C now in this triangle we have 2 C + B
is equal to Pi because the sum of the
angles in a triangle is equal to Pi
radians so we can solve this equation
for C to get that c is equal to <
14 so we're now pretty much ready to do
the main calculation we will first
calculate the area of this circular
sector the area of a circular sector is
r^2 / 2ti Theta in this case we have R 2
multiplied by 2 C the central angle is 2
C and then we divide by two since R is
equal to 1 and C is equal to piun over
14 this simplifies to be < over 14
we now need to subtract the area of two
of these Isles triangles let's first
figure out the area of one
triangle construct a
perpendicular now we have a triangle
where the base is equal to 1 and we
divide this into two segments of 1/2 so
the length of the height will be equal
to 1/2 multiplied by the tangent of c
and the base is equal to 1 so the area
of the triangle is 12 * the base of 1 *
the height which is 12 * tangent of C
this simplifies to be tangent of pi/ 14
all over 4 now we want the area of two
triangles so this will be 12 * the
tangent of pi/
14 so we now take the area of the
circular sector subtract the areas of
two triangles and we get the area of
this wedge and that will be equal to Pi
14 minus 12 * the tangent of < / 14 to
get the area of the entire coin we
multiply this by 7 so we get 7 W is
equal to < / 2 - 7 /2 * the tangent of
pi over
14 and that's the
answer thanks for making us one of the
best communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time
a